and now it's time for Quebec corner with
your shovel and Johnny problem oh hello
everybody welcome to Quebec corner I am
your host Pio Shambo and I'm is earth
brother
jeonggi Kambli and today we're gonna
talk about something very special
okay lots of people's know the GSP is
fighting jig shield at UFC 129 but some
people they wanna know is GSP gonna win
that fights I know that's like saying is
Mae West better than Oh Steph GSP is
going to beat Jake shield because GSP is
the better stand up gia spelled the
better loot the wrestling my weight my
way GSP is better condition and JSP is
better looking fresh mango look at this
no and GSP he's gonna be better father
you're gonna see about it very well yeah
I would want him as my father and me we
also want them like that but after GSP
is gonna switch the floor with Jake
shield who's left for that guy to fight
Jon Fitch call this John Fitch nobody
gonna want to see you dry hump another
opponent
tabernac look you want to do that why
don't you go train with Jake shield in
San Francisco see you're supposed to
fight that guy not by um dinners and a
movie and get up at a that's right once
moment hello Matt
why me
I'm not using the internet at home you
can use the tariff
no magic trees below
Judy's name part of Jesus colles what's
that it's my new telephone that looks
fancy we have the budget for that y0 I
figure it's important for business
where's the string on no no no there's
no count on this it's a cellular phone
you keep it in your car yes see I can
almost put deaths in my focus but for no
joke okay GSP is gonna be Jake shield
worse than that time I almost take his
last lap you don't want to do that but
now I don't do that no more JSP teach me
you only use your power for good
that's it and that's the GS speed the
power is GSP is more than a fighter is
everything GSP is in the way I talked to
my brother GSP is in the way I say hello
to my mother GSP is even in the way
sometime you share your last llama on
jasp is everything that's it that's it
see